I think
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
until we forget that it's a lie
all right my friends here we are once
again with another Game of Thrones actor
describing how they really felt after
the final season of the show that's
right ladies and gentlemen our old
friend Lord Varys is on the long list of
actors who did not like how Game of
Thrones writers David and Dan ended the
series now I'm sure most of you already
suspected this if you saw how he reacted
during the final read of the last season
it's now one of the most infamous videos
surrounding the Game of Thrones
documentary I think most of you already
knew he was disgusted by how David and
Dan had Varys leave the show it was no
secret how he actually felt because it
was written all over his face now
although we already had a good idea of
how he felt in that moment he finally
revealed exactly how he was thinking
during his final days on the show and
how varys's ending affected him moving
forward during his brand new interview
Game of Thrones actor Colin Leaf Hill
admitted how he was frustrated with the
show's rushed final Seasons this new
article says the shadow of Game of
Thrones divisive final season still
hangs over the franchise remaining as a
source of incredible discipline
appointment not only for its fans but
also its Stars Game of Thrones actor
conleth Hill who was the eunuch varus on
all eight seasons of the series set in a
new interview with the times that he
believes disagreements with HBO and its
showrunners David benioff and DB Weiss
led to confusing plot developments in
the show's final stretch right up until
the last two series I had no complaints
at all he told the times I just felt
frustrated with the last couple of
Seasons because Varys wasn't the
all-knowing character he had been I
think the writers wanted to do one thing
to end it and the studio HBO wanted to
do another I felt that the last season
was a bit rushed I wasn't consolable but
now I'm fine about it now Hill's not
lying about being inconsolable after
Varys was executed and won a game of
thrones final episodes The Bells the
actor told Entertainment Weekly in an
in-depth interview that nothing could
console him after learning the fate of
his character he went on to say you
can't help feeling that you failed in
some way that you haven't lived up to
some expectation that you didn't know
about the only thing that can Souls you
are the people who worked a lot harder
than you and who are in the same boat so
that helps I don't think anybody who
hasn't been through it can identify with
it they think what's all the fuss about
you're all finishing anyway but you take
it personally you can't help it although
he'll ultimately thought that varys's
death was noble and in line with the
character's ideals he still had his
disappointments for example he lamented
the lack of closure between Varys and
his longtime political rival
Littlefinger as a Duo of lowborn
characters who claim the ranks of power
through skill and cunning Varys and
littlefinger's combative conversations
were highlights of Game of Thrones early
Seasons that was of course before the
story had them Go in different
directions now as we all know
Littlefinger ultimately met his fate in
Winterfell at the hands of Arya Stark he
goes on to say I was very bummed to not
have a final scene with him I was bummed
to not have any reaction to him dying if
he was my Nemesis that's been my feeling
the last couple Seasons that my
character became more peripheral that
they concentrated on others more that's
fine it's the nature of a
multi-character show it was kind of
frustrating as a whole it's been
overwhelmingly positive and Brilliant
but I suppose the last couple Seasons
weren't my favorite now like I said
earlier I think most of us knew this is
how he really felt after watching The
Game of Thrones documentary I know I
certainly did and I remember a lot of
fans lashed out at me for thinking any
actor did not like how the show ended
I've always said the actors would
eventually reveal how they really
thought about David and Dan's ending it
was only a matter of time before they
started discussing it out into the open
I know he's not the only one who felt
this way either we already know Emilio
was devastated by Danny's ending and it
wasn't only because the show was over
she more or less admitted she felt sick
by the fact that Daenerys was
essentially made into the villain at the
very end and who can blame her for
feeling that way we also know kit
Harrington wasn't satisfied either which
is why he wants to make the Jon Snow
show he basically wants to rewrite Jon
Snow's ending on his own now I'm sure
there will still be some of you who
disagree with this but you will see this
happen more often once the actors are no
longer afraid to speak their minds right
now some of them aren't going to want to
say anything out of fear of losing their
job but the truth will always come out
eventually I know I'm still waiting for
someone to write a novel about all the
dirty little secrets that were happening
behind the scenes that would obviously
be an instant bestseller but that's not
gonna happen just yet because we're
still not that far removed from Game of
Thrones final season either way I do
believe it will happen at a later date
now let me know what you think about the
new interview down below do you think
his feelings are valid is he justified
how many of you actually think Varys was
mishandled at the end of the show I want
to hear what all of you have to say
about this one as always I want to thank
all of you for watching another video I
hope you all have a great day I will see
you again very soon bye
have you shot your final scenes yet and
are you happy with how things ended
best season ever
without telling us anything because I
know you can't is are you all happy with
the way you use things with the outcome
of the
shower
it's a little bit Avengers assembled
it's a little bit kind of like well that
was totally what season seven was all
about yeah
exactly character development
but it
I really need to shut up you're brave
oh my God
I couldn't let you go without asking you
a little question about Game of Thrones
sure
if you could describe the season finale
of Game of Thrones in one word
how would you describe them
disappointing
no epic I don't know one of those ones
it's terrifying down there we're in a
crypt nobody thought of that he's
bringing all the dead people back to
life and they put the women and children
in a crypt with all the dead people so
crap
Tyrion this is smart but I guess not
that smart
but I hate to tell you that
unfortunately Madison is God were you
gutted about that on a person I was
goddess I was Goddard because I mean a
number of you I'm sure have read the
books and uh I've read the books and I
have reason to expect oh I've got a
journey here in fact if I'm honest I
thought oh I'm really looking forward to
this season I'm going to have more to do
I'm going to get my teeth into something
I'm really looking forward to did you
have words did you say anything well I
did I did ask and and uh give an
argument why I thought Barrison should
stay but at the end of the day I mean
you know Dan and David you know they've
worked out what they wanted to do and
you know if you've planned your book
that the butler did it and then you read
an internet someone has figured out that
the butler did it and you suddenly
change in Midstream and it was the
chambermaid who did it then you screw up
the whole book because you get these
this foreshadowing early on and you've
got these little Clues you planted now
they're dead ends and you have to
introduce other Clues and you're
retconning it's a mess we hope to kind
of avoid the expected and Jon Snow has
always been the hero the one who's in
the Savior but it just didn't seem right
to us for this for this moment how do
you feel about the way that it ends
um there are no better writers in
television than Dan Weiss and David
benionoff they ended it brilliantly
better than I could have imagined and uh
you people are in for it
what are you people are in for